Hello everyone, this is English. This channel is making videos of tech industry career lifestyle,
etc.
chasen be over Mie Beaver Winger Meeting perele
to do
fread Harles Pruss b Meeting Bar
-Some border 4 a doodle
voodoo good srp school e to do a peace force blue do
re weber render aso peropero learning endnote 4
se 52 to do
voodoo faceter japanese for a 4 f do do
our up needs
goo do
roudo 4 se blues wither
render  to do
movie battle league Rausu t nester jeans for use up
teaser rain goods for a who do
eh green re japanese 4 re 4 as far apg villages
for me phase weather world diffuse Hikokura Italy
rde saramander forever re pap do
sender  so World Ti Jenne Mahjong is my Japanese 3
I don't have that confidence, but I can speak normally and read and write normally,
so I'm grateful for that, too.  I'm really grateful to be able to talk to my grandma and
reader free n 3 star
Suwanosawa Iku Variety tb Gendramanse k pop star ardrone
breno Rudo
voodoo ono asino World Are asan Pendrower
jr japanese Moomin app up as pou dou dou 4
Fashion and Move Can 4 x Loose including welcoming
find Peapo t Turk tu Amazing that make s find
people who do me I noticed that
there aren't many buckies who speak that Japanese.  When
I became an adult, I really thought that I should make a bar where I can speak Japanese,
so it's very difficult to make that bar, and I especially
live in a place where there are many Japanese people.
The fighting me me in fun to do so wow
finding japanese all right calm early show 2
room ear ascender ender ender ore to do
b
andere to do
rear the voodoo  Wheel 14th moon
Boo Boo enoden dare you do
voodoo forever Lesson Ayer Re 20 Speed Fare 4 kids
o do in anore
ia ndege Goods orenge Ah Ranger 2 do Can y
u talk?  It's so much fun
to talk turn surfing with a good family, and
I recently thought that it had a big impact on my identity, so I
'd like to teach Kansai Ben when I have a child in the future.  But at
least I want to teach Japanese. Don't tell Sawahime Up Smile Up #bar
Hare
Brudu a led er en us e to do af File Otsu Masu 10 s
released to do s 4 ab
Tarres  Formerless preen zu winker lever voodoo
pou dou dou
rename to do
arso binding faren refuse to do do
4 meses per me to do
sa pou dou dou
voodoo forever swear to do
rear japanese meeting
forever eater
on face keren osk
reir arthur style gui  Fire legs are you doing
I think that the word for my body is Japanese because my body is Japanese.
I
'm gonna give you a greeting seed away battle
.
I think I use
Instagram to collect that question, so please follow me if you have any
ost asobono rondelle Jeb aap deno sweet
pops win-win se
japanese nba to do fos speaker please
rerere mrr  Parenty Me Dove 4 f and Aalen who do
bd re in some power canine effector 6
bye